I blunder The Rook this game but
pretended it was a peace sacrifice so
this is how it went I played E4 my
opponent went for the Sicilian Defense
he went Knight to C6 and I played B for
the wing Gambit he accepted I grabbed
the center with Ponte D4 and D5 so this
is all very standard stuff C4 sometimes
they capture alpassan which you should
do he declined he played Queen to D6 D5
and now I should play Bishop to B2 but
uh I didn't I played Bishop to E2 and
blunder the full rook and this is where
the fun starts he uh I block he captures
The Rook I castle and now Bishop to D7 I
played C5 he played rook d8 and I played
C6 and now look at this B captures in C6
D captures and he played Bishop the C
and Bishop to F5 and now Pawn to C7 and
he can resign he took my queen I played
Bishop to C6 check he blocked with the
bishop and now I just promoted to a
queen and delivered a very nice
Checkmate so sometimes even if you
blunder you can still pretend it was
intentional see you soon